a charity is warning that public health
could be at risk because GP surgeries
are refusing to register asylum seekers
doctors of the world says almost forty
percent of patients that's had to
register had been turned away Harriet
Hadfield has this exclusive report this
is a clinic for patients who can't or
won't get medical help anywhere else and
many end up here because they've been
wrongly turned away from a local GP
surgery how are you today sanjeevani Sri
Lankan asylum seeker was refused
registration he's made the four-hour
roundtrip to be seen by a GP from
doctors of the world another thing I was
very worried I had so much pain and
really needed help I showed my Asylum
letter but they said they couldn't
register me because the letter had no
address his doctor jenny is a volunteer
who works four days a month at the
clinic these are vulnerable people who
need to be able to register with a GP
you need to access the health care so we
need to be flexible and find a way to
get unregistered NHS guidelines say all
asylum seekers and refugees are eligible
to register with the GP practice last
year doctors of the world made 849
registration attempts between march and
october thirty-nine percent were refused
by the practices in red most of them in
london reasons include thirty-nine
percent with no ID thirty-six percent no
proof of address while thirteen percent
specifically because of immigration
status according to the Royal College of
GPS the problem is more about paperwork
than discrimination I don't think GPS
are sitting in their consulting rooms
thinking let's block care to refugees I
think it's the complexity of what's
going on in reception and I think our
receptions need support I think this is
a difficult role most of the people
we've met here at the clinic don't want
to appear on camera many are afraid it
could
mention air clean for asylum or there
could be sent home and it's that same
fear that prevents many other people
from seeking any kind of medical
treatment at all dr. al story is an
expert in tuberculosis so from his point
of view the situation poses a real risk
to public health well if people get
turned away from primary care and
they're symptomatic and they could have
Chipper kilo sees the consequences of
that are transmission in the community
it's in all our interests to diagnose TV
early and ensure that people can access
diagnostic services would you mind
telling me a bit about the background a
bit about how you came to the UK and
things doctors of the world have helped
sanji even sign up with his local
surgery that GPS across England are
under pressure to ensure frontline staff
understand exactly what the rules are
and register all eligible patients
Harriet Hadfield Sky News East London